good afternoon cs109 we are live and
back in class I hope you had a fantastic
weekend and I hope you're ready for a
little bit more popularity education ah
yeah feeling the probability of us okay
we are going to be learning some very
cool things today before we jump into
any of that though a couple quick
announcements as you probably know
problem set one is out it will be due
this Friday though there is a little bit
of a grace period in case you missed the
deadline uh section assignments if you
don't get them today that means
something went wrong and somehow we
didn't get your assignment uh they will
be going out today uh if you can't make
your time or you need a swap see the
post there is more details about this
um talk about this PSAT party in a
second and as always or you know I've
gotten this habit oh this should be fall
22. I've gotten this habit of putting up
examples for today's for the lecture on
the problem set app you can go to uh the
link directly or you can go find cs109
go find today's lecture
to do not the fastest internet in the
world
and once the website loads after a
little suspense you can go to lecture
lecture four and if you hit the little
rocket ship you can go enter today's
code and follow along
wow man internet you're really stepping
on my point here anyways the code for
today is silly owl
uh there you go not that important but
you now know
okay
this problem set party hey there's some
really cool people here at Stanford I
want to tell you about two of them uh
uh our PhD students and they're
interested in the future of online
education uh and for massive online
classes one of the things they're
interested in how they can get peers
working with peers and they've built a
lot of really cool technology and they
want to try it out in cs109 so you might
have noticed in the PSAT app there's
this new button and it has this number
that's how many people are online has
anybody tried clicking this button
couple folks if you click this button
it's like would you like to learn with
somebody else and you're like okay and
if you hit okay then it kind of waits
till somebody else in class hits the
same button and it'll pop up a little
video for you guys uh obviously you know
nothing about this is for grade it's
just for fun uh but you're kind of
contributing to this experiment in for
massive online courses it could be a
cool feature that could change the game
in cs109 there's so many as we we can
interact it'll probably be just a small
little demo but if you come to the pset
app at 9 00 PM if you hit that button it
would be great if we could try and
overload our server and if anything goes
wrong just let us know
it's just for fun it's not that
important but you know it is important
the stuff that we talked about last week
so just to recall last week's Focus was
really uncounting and we counted lots of
different things we counted orderings of
objects we counted combinations of
objects and we put objects in buckets uh
and you know one of the big meta
takeaways Beyond those three skills
sometimes you get very large numbers
like in the end of last class we talked
about how many ways can you order 52
unique cards well that's just 52
factorial we learned this last week but
you know one of the ideas is
combinations and permutations can really
lead to large numbers like this is what
52 factorial looks like if you wrote it
out and on the end of last class if you
check the slides there's an explanation
for why that leads to a claim that if
you have a particular ordering of cards
with high probability you can say no one
has ever seen that exact ordering
anyways we talked about combinations of
permutation and then we got into the
world of probability probabilities were
numbers between zero and one we started
out with the three Axiom terms of
probability
um
the first two we talked about
semantically the third one that I
promised we would talk about a little
bit more later now is that time
the third Axiom probability talks about
events and it talks about the
probability of either one of the two
events happening so either e or F or
call this a set notation for or
and if you say what's the probability of
either of these two events happening the
third Axiom probably says it's the sum
of the two probabilities
if an important if it turns out these
two events are mutually exclusive
we mentioned this really quickly last
time but I thought it'd be worth just
taking a moment to go a little bit
deeper into what this assumption is
saying
so all events are really sets of
outcomes
and if this event is this particular set
of outcomes welcome to my little tile
space and I would call this set of
outcomes event e and I'm going to call
this set of outcomes event F they're
mutually exclusive if no event is in
both or no outcome is in both events
and the claim of this third Axiom is hey
in this case calculating the probability
of either e or F is pretty simple we're
just going to calculate the sum of the
probability masses
now if you imagine like the outcome
space of your world is any one of these
tiles
and if you imagine they're equally
likely then we can say that the
probability of e is seven outcomes over
50 and probably F would be four outcomes
over 50 and so the
third Axiom probably says the
probability of e or F would be just
adding those two things together so 7
over 50 plus 4 this is supposed to say
over 50 equals 11 over 50.
there you go and that's one of the
things that we assume it works for more
than two events if you have a whole
bunch of events uh if they're all
mutually exclusive so there's no event
that's in there's no outcome that's in
two events you can just add
probabilities
we'll hit this a lot but I just wanted
to say it in a little bit more detail
than we said it on Friday wahoo
okay and we'll get into this more when
we practice it but for now you should
start to feel that if events are have
this special property of no outcomes in
both events probability of or is going
to be easy
on Friday though I said there's this
other really intuitive law of
probability which we could prove and
this is intuitive law that we're going
to use today
it says the probability of something not
happening is one minus the probability
of it happening
okay that kind of makes sense but I just
want to show you what a proven
probability would look like we can prove
this just using those three axioms in
fact we can start with the third Axiom
of probability
e or not e so either event e happens or
event e doesn't happen
this is a little bit of a mind game to
see if you understand Mutual exclusivity
but it turns out e n not e must be
mutually exclusive
because is there an outcome where e
happens and not e also happens
no one of those two has to happen so
they must be mutually exclusive there's
no outcome that can be in both e and not
e therefore by the 30 Axiom this
probability statement is just going to
be the sum of the probabilities on their
own okay you guys following along
either e or not e not happening has to
cover the whole sample space right
because everything in the universe is
either e or not e so that is the entire
universe of outcomes
and this probability the sample space
one of the axioms of probability Axiom 2
says that this probability of something
happening is one and at the point where
here we can see hey if we're trying to
derive that we're really close we just
need to move probably e not happening to
be on its own side in which case you get
probably of e not happening equals one
minus the probability of e happening you
know this is what a proof and
probability looks like it probably isn't
that surprising to you and we can use
these derivations we've got so far to
prove further things okay let's take a
moment and take questions if there's
anything confusing about this let me
know
okay fantastic
then I'm going to finish our warm-up
with a question I'm going to give you
guys some time to think about because I
think it's really fun
one of my favorite things in life is
Serendipity when things happen which you
didn't really expect to happen and they
they seem to evoke the fruit of the
random tree uh and they bring some good
vibes to you okay so here's the problem
that I pose to you
Stanford has 17
000 people
I don't know how many people you're
friends with I'd say I'm friends with
about a hundred maybe that's an
overestimate but you know if you walk
into a room and there's 268 random
people that's how many people were
enrolled in the class at the beginning
of the quarter but now we're up to
something like 315.
what's the probability that someone is
one of your friends that one of the 268
people perhaps in this class uh is one
of your friends we have to make
assumption we're going to assume that
every person in this class is equally
likely to be any of the 1700 people at
Stanford
if we make that assumption we can
calculate the probability that if you
chose a subset of 268 that at least one
person would be a friend
so
that's your challenge and I'm going to
give you this Pro tip
you know how the probability of E not e
not happening is equal to 1 minus
probability of e happening that allows
you to go from the probability of e not
happening to the probability of e
happening
sometimes it's way easier to calculate
the probability that an event doesn't
happen this is one of those cases
so think about my question as being the
probability of e naught happening I'm
asking what's the chance that out of
this 268 people you don't see someone
you know
last Friday's class we talked about
outcome spaces where every outcome was
equally likely if you can utilize that
we can solve this problem it's a pretty
hefty warm-up problem but if you can
solve this as kind of like you know
upper Watermark of the sort of equally
likelihood outcome space probability
questions I'd asked you do you guys want
to get started this talk about it with
the person next you see if you can
summarize what you're trying to do and
see if you can solve that problem okay
get to know a friend
okay okay
I love this it's such a hefty problem
um
so
let's think about this together
I want to figure out what are what's the
probability of not seeing anybody that
you know so uh out of 17 000 people we
walk into a room with 268 people what's
probably I know none of them
and I want to set this up as a
probability with equally likelihood
outcome spaces
if you want to do that you have to
figure out the size of the sample space
and the size of the event space and you
want to make sure that every outcome in
the sample space was equally likely so
did anyone first come up with a sample
space that they were happy with
and that's like every outcome like what
what's an outcome of this experiment too
while we're thinking about it yes
well I mean your sample space would have
to be 17 000 choose 268. so that's the
size of the sample space is 17
choose 268. but what's one element in
that sample space
yeah the person next to you
um if you like a random selection of two
human specific people yeah so every
outcome in the sample space IS 268
people chosen
how many outcomes are there well there's
all the ways you could choose 268 people
from the 17 000. that's a lot
and a subset of those will be such that
you don't know anybody in the class
did anyone have a way of counting how
many subsets of this set have no friends
in the class
yeah an idea over there uh you just
subtract 17
000 maybe a number of friends from
seventeen thousand and choose 268 again
so the way you could
you don't know still
see people but instead of pulling from
seventeen thousand we're going to pull
from all the people who you don't know
how many people do you not know is 17
000 minus your number of friends and I
said I know a hundred people
so it'd be sixteen thousand nine hundred
choose 268.
what are those odds so I know 100 people
I walk into a room of 268 what are the
odds that I don't see a single person
that I know
so let's do we got math.com
seventeen thousand minus a hundred
choose two hundred and sixty eight
okay and I'm just going to call that my
numerator
oh
that's a big number my denominator
though is going to be math dot
combination Seventeen hundred thousand
choose 268. so the same number except in
the this part we're pulling from
everyone in Stanford not just the people
I don't know
and if you do numerator divided by
denominator
what's this point two zero mean
it's a number between zero and one
yeah it's a probability it's a problem I
don't know anyone
if there's a 20 probably I don't know
anyone what's the chance I do know
somebody
is that wild if you only know 100 people
on campus and you walk into a room with
268 you are very likely to know at least
one person
wow isn't counting cool what a time to
be alive
uh certainly there is this major key
here
and the major key here is
oh my God would this problem have been
much much harder if I just tried to
count all the ways that I could know at
least one person because I need to know
all the ways that there's one person I
know two people I know three people I
know four people I know five oh that's
so much this is counting zero people
and then the chance I know one or more
is going to be one minus the chance that
I know zero people
sometimes life is so much easier when
you calculate the probability of an
event not happening
stretching your question
looked like a good stretch I can go from
stretch too okay more stretching I like
this okay my daughter figured out what
yoga was over the weekend and she's like
the most aggressive yoga but she's like
yoga every morning I don't know if she
gets the vibe but she gets the
stretching part
to set up this problem what would it be
like one leg set for the bathroom
yeah I always start with thinking about
the all the outcomes of the experiment
so like what are all the outcomes of
experiment and that was thinking of
getting rooms of 268 people and I tried
to figure out how could I count all the
ways you could get a room of 268 people
and then once I counted those and the
way I count these both gave me the
feeling that everything was equally
likely like no room of 268 people is
going to be more likely than another and
once I'm there I'm in a good spot then
the chance is just I need to count the
smaller number of people that satisfy
the event I care about
The Meta step which we kind of glossed
over because I told you let's just do
this from the beginning is whenever I
approach a probability problem I think
is it easier to calculate the
probability directly or the probability
complement of the event complement in
this case we just started by going with
the event complement
good question and end of review
we've got a growing tool set and today
we're going to add some awesome tools to
the tool set we're going to add chain
rule definition conditional probability
you're a lot learn the law of total
probability which is as impressive as it
sounds and the law that is so much more
impressive than it sounds based theorem
we're going to hit some of the classics
in probability Theory we're going to add
them all to your probability tool set
starts with one Concept in fact if there
was a central idea to get today is this
idea of conditional probability
conditional probabilities really where
probability starts to get exciting it's
how you can update beliefs so if You
observe some information how do
probabilities change
do you guys remember we talked about
Dice and when we were talking about
equally likely outcome spaces we
introduced the world of dice we said
let's say you have two dice and you want
to know the probability that some of
your dice is seven well we set up here's
all the outcomes of rolling two dice
and there's a subset of outcomes here
that lead to the sum being seven and we
said that because these are equally
likelihood events we could say the
probability of the sum being seven was
just one two three four five six divided
by 36 total outcomes
equally likely outcome spaces gave us
this way to calculate the probability
but now let's change our problem a
little bit I'm going to say not that the
sum comes to 7 but that the sum comes to
four and my question for you just to get
us started is what's the best outcome
for the first days
so
um so the two dice we're going to call
the first ice dice one we call count the
second dice dice two we care about them
something before what do I want dice one
to be well I say it's just as good if
dice one and three or dice one is either
one or three well I say it's equally
good if dice one is one two or three
do you think two one dice one is the
best
or do you think either none more than
one of these answers is right
think about it for a moment don't talk
to the person next to you just
appreciate
foreign
to think about this a little bit deeper
let's talk about all the outcomes where
two dice end up equaling four so if you
take our 36 different outcomes of
rolling two dice here are the three
outcomes where your dice and up being
sum to four
it if we think about the probability of
the event where the two dice equals four
our sample space is 36 elements in it
there's these three events that lead to
the sum being four and then just using
the math we learned on Friday the
probability of the event is just going
to be the size of this event space
divided by the size of the sample space
so 1 over 12.
but I said the idea of today we really
want you to understand is this idea of
conditional probability and the
conditional probability starts to
introduce terms like this
what's the probability of some event
given you've already observed some other
information
and to practice I want us to enter this
world of conditional probability with
the simple example of what if the first
dice was two
what's the probability that my two dice
sum to four given that dice 1 is equal
to 2.
there's no uncertainty as to whether not
dice one equals two I'm telling you Dice
1 was 2. and if I tell you what that
dice one was two I've asked you to
calculate probability in the world where
we have information
and you can imagine when computers and
probabilities got them together there's
lots of situations where we have some
information if I tell you that F has
already happened that dice one is
already two what happens to our world of
probability
the first thing that happens is there's
no longer 36 possible outcomes to my
experiment
it's not possible that dice one is one
it's not possible that dice one is six
the only outcomes that are coherent with
my claim that dice one was two are these
six outcomes does that make sense
so once I told you Dice one was two the
world of possible outcomes shrunk quite
a lot
now out of all of these possible
outcomes which ones of them lead to the
two dice adding up to be four
there's just this one if you think about
if I tell you the first dice is two
the only way you're going to end up with
a four is if that second dice is two
mathematically we'll end up with a
probability of your event going up from
1 12 to 1 6.
so you're probably an event happening
increased When You observe that F had
occurred that your first X was two
the outcome space shrunk to every
outcome that was consistent with what
you observed the events base shrunk to
every outcome that was consistent with
what you observed
and your probability increased
because even though there's fewer things
in E and there's fewer things in F all
these events e there are larger ratio of
things than S
does that make sense though I told you
what's the chance of getting a four it's
kind of low but now I told you the first
dice was a two and it's a little bit
higher
if I told you your first ice was a six
what's your probability of getting a
four
yeah and so if I tell you your first ice
is a two you're like still in the game
so anyways back to my question
if the first dice wasn't two but rather
it was three
what's your probability of the two
summing up to four
1 6 because if the first ISO is a three
again we'll have six things in the
outcome space and again only one of
those will lead to an outcome where the
two dice add up to four there's only one
dice on the second Throw That Could lead
to a four it'll still be one over six
what if that first dice was a one
it's still one over six because if I
observe that the first ice is one the
sample space has got to be all the
things consistent with the first bit I
should be one so get one one two one
three one four one five one six and the
invent space will just be one three
because there's only one outcome that
leads to a four
does it matter if the first text is a
one two or a three they will all lead to
a 1 6 probability of your sum being a
four
and this is our gentle introduction to
the world of conditional probability if
we observe some information our
probabilities will change and that
changing probability is what we mean
when we talk about conditional
probabilities
it has its own notation when we talk
about e condition on F we'll write it
with this big vertical bar and if you
read that in English it would still read
as the probability of some event e given
that a different event has already
occurred
it's known as conditioning on F and it's
when probability starts to get way more
exciting because you can calculate
interesting derivative probabilities
two things happen when you observe an
event your sample space shrinks to be
every outcome that's consistent with the
observation your event space shrinks to
be everything that's consistent with the
observation and your probability can
change let's go back to our world of
outcome spaces in my tiles and think
about what this means
here's event e it's in red here is event
F it's in blue ooh are these two events
mutually exclusive
no because there's these three events
there's these three outcomes where both
events happen
when I talk about event conditioning on
F
we're going to enter the world where F
has happened
so
if we want to calculate the probability
of e given f
we're going to take all of our outcomes
and the sample space is going to be all
the outcomes are consistent with f
happening and this numerator is going to
be all the outcomes of our event that
are consistent with f happening it's
like we shrink into the world of the
green outcome spaces so if You observe F
it's like f has happened only these
things are possible outcomes anymore
because I've told you f has happened
so our outcome space will just become f
and the event space will be all these
things where are in both E and F
that's a little bit mathematical what if
we learned about this using a bit of
Netflix which we'll do in just a second
I want to point out a little bit you
know there's this notation you'll
sometimes see two sets without a symbol
between them
that's an implicit and and we'll talk a
little about notation at the end of
class I want to make sure nobody gets
confused
when you condition on F happening you
enter the world where F has occurred
your sample space will become F and your
event space will become all the events
that are consistent with your event
space and F
okay
definition of conditional probability
it has this definition mathematically
the probability of e happening given
that F happens is equal to the
probability of E and F happening so all
the events that are consistent with f
happening divide by the probability of f
happening there you go
there is another way you could write
this exact same equation you could take
this probably of F and since it's a
non-zero or you know since the number
between zero and one so it's not
negative well actually that's fine you
can just multiply on both sides because
that's math
you can rearrange this equation and get
probably E and F happening equals
probability of f times probably e given
F we'll call this a chain rule
some people ask what happens if the
probability of f is zero
mathematically won't this blow up
and let's always refer back during this
lecture to what conditioning probability
means it means we've observed some
events is happening this is probably e
given that we've observed F has already
taken place
what would it mean to say I've observed
F has taken place but the probability of
f is zero
it's like it's probably f is zero it's
impossible for f to happen right
How Can You observe it if the
probability of it happening is zero
you've observed the impossible so if
your conditioning on F that means you're
told me f has happened it can't be the
case that probably if f is zero
the probability of e times f is this
yeah fantastic so this is what's the
chance that e happens
given that F has already happened
and this is what's the probability of
both of them happening and it's so
subtle it's so subtle so if you say e
given F you've told me f is happening
I've entered that world and if you say
enf I don't know if f is going to happen
and I have to think about F happening
and E happening simultaneously
super subtle but with something we're
going to hit a whole bunch today because
that's exactly one of the most important
questions to ask
now I've decided that this is very
mathematical and a little bit hard to
understand just from definition so let's
do something a little bit more intuitive
we're going to do some Netflix and learn
and we're going to think about how
conditional probabilities change and
we'll get some nice intuition around it
one of my favorite movies in the world
is this movie Life is Beautiful this is
not your favorite movie we can talk
about that and I will convince you
that's one of the greatest films ever
made
okay
um just
just to be cheeky we're going to talk
about the probably that a user watches a
movie in the context of this streaming
uh platform called Netflix
now what's the sample space of somebody
watching or not watching Life is
Beautiful well there's two outcomes
somebody can either watch it or not
watch it and the event that I care about
is that they watch it is the probability
of event one half
no we could only do the size of the
event space divided by sample space if
each of these outcomes was equally
likely so it's not one half so how do
you think we could get the probability
of somebody watching it assume we're
Netflix how do you think Netflix does
this
they very much care about the
probability that somebody watches a
movie
[Music]
they can they could infer it it turns
out Netflix is so big they can calculate
it directly they can just know the
problem that you like watch a movie
that was a good idea yeah they take a
look what other movies we've watched
yeah that's very
even simpler thing that they do that's a
very good idea but there's an even
simpler thing that they can do yeah
and if they put on the French page what
they can do is they how many people
actually watch it
uh and so here's one of the things I do
it's even simpler than what you guys are
thinking about they go back to that core
definition of what a probability is and
they just count
if they want to know the probably
somebody watches a movie they say well
we have like a billion people on Netflix
I can see I can think of each of those
as an experiment and I can see what
fraction of those lead to a watch and
that will estimate the probability that
a user watches the movie and it's like
they're going back to that core
definition of probability
and the core definition probably is like
if I ran infinite experiments what
subset would lead to my event
so Netflix you know 50 million point
nine 50.9 million people are on Netflix
of which 10.3 million watch this movie
you would say that probably somebody
watches this movie is 0.20
does that make sense even simpler than a
lot of people a lot of people have these
very good ideas if we could look at what
they watch for other movies
that would not give you the probability
of the event on the on its own but it
would give you something more
interesting you guys are going down a
more interesting path which is where
we're all going today
for lots of movies you could look at the
probability that somebody watches the
movie and it's just going to be counting
what fraction of users watch that movie
but these numbers are not that
interesting
the interesting thing is how do these
probabilities change when you observe
interesting stuff like they watched
another movie and this is what everyone
was getting to when we were thinking
about the answer to that question
because maybe we all care about this
problem that's where we intuitively go
to First
the more interesting problem Oh I have a
typo here the more interesting problem
is what is the probability that somebody
watches this movie condition that I've
seen they've watched another movie
so I'm going to introduce another movie
that I like called Coda which I think is
fantastic has anyone's seen this there's
a two versions of code yeah isn't it so
good it's freaking amazing okay anyways
so now I want to change our
probabilities not just what fraction of
users watch this movie
but if I tell you that a user has
watched coda how does that change my
belief that they'll watch life is
beautiful and welcome to the world of
conditional probabilities and these are
the more interesting probabilities
because you're more uh tuned to the
person that you're Computing a
probability for
if you want to know the conditional
probability you know here's the
definition
it's the probability that somebody
watches life is beautiful and they watch
coda divided by the probability that
they like they watch Coda this is just
our definition of conditional
probability
both of these could be estimated using
the fact that Netflix is very large you
can say this is the number of people who
watch both
divide by the number of people on
Netflix is a good approximation of the
probability that somebody watches both
the number of people who watch and this
should say Coda divided by a number of
people of Netflix is a good
approximation of the probability that
somebody watches coda
and if you cancel out the number of
people on Netflix and you update this I
used to like Emily it's still a good
movie but then I saw Coda and I'm like I
have to update
I have to update my example for my like
new second favorite movie is just so
touching
okay
if you calculate this probability you
get a different number by the way when
you cancel that number of people who
like Netflix you're you're left with a
number of people who've watched both
so you know number of outcomes are kind
of consistent with E and F divided by a
number of outcomes uh in F of people who
watched coda
and these two tell two different stories
these two numbers we calculated tell two
different stories and it's gonna be
really hard for you to distinguish them
at first but cs109 you're gonna be such
a pro at this when you walk out
the first number was what's the
probability that somebody watches this
movie given no other information
and this number is what's the
probability that somebody watches this
movie given the information that I know
they've watched this other movie
and these changing probabilities are a
big deal
okay we can do this for every single
movie you know we took life as beautiful
and we figure out the probability of
that given F and we can do that for
every single probability that we
calculated before
they'll mostly change not all of them
but most of them will change some will
go down if I tell you that somebody's
watched Coda it's possible for it to be
less likely for them to watch a movie
that you care about
or as possible for the probability to go
up quite a lot
the probabilities can change a whole
bunch when you get some information and
that's the big idea of conditional
probabilities
I want to stop there I want you to talk
to the person next you see if you have a
cool question you can ask me try and
summarize what we've talked about and
see if you can come up with something
that could be clarifying okay go talk
talk
okay
I want a cool question anyone find some
of this confusing it'll be confusing the
first time you see it
but it becomes it's important so I want
to take clarification questions great
time and lecture questions
is this concrete example making a little
bit more apparent than maybe the dice
one
since nodding any questions
that came up
so any movie can be conditioned
so for example they might not Star Wars
and Coda could be pretty unrelated
but you can still ask the question
what's the chance that somebody watches
Star Wars given that they watch Coda
even if they're totally unrelated movies
with no with no common themes but if I'm
telling you the the this piece of
observation that the person watched this
movie
and it can change my belief of the
probability that they watch Star Wars
this probability went down
it kind of tells you that those movies
are unrelated
and if they're unrelated if somebody
tells you you've watched Coda maybe it
gives you information that they know
they like that kind of movie and if they
like that kind of movie maybe it tells
you they don't like this kind of movie
so then maybe that's why the probability
is going down
we can talk about lots of causal
mechanisms why these probabilities go
down up or down
but you can still ask the question
and when you ask the question you know
we can get a numerical answer we'll get
deeper into the whys as we get deeper
into conditional probability does that
help yeah I guess yeah
you know
yeah some people are interested in all
movies some people have genre
preferences there's this like deep
psychological human causality that's
going on and despite all that causality
you can still ask conditional of any two
events that you care about
and we should talk about that deep
causality and I'd love to get into that
after class yes
yeah yeah what's the relationship
between like conditional probability and
like it's a compliment of an event like
is it meaning what's the probability of
e given that not e oh that's the problem
ready
I tell you that I mean it's a really
good question because it talks about the
semantics we enter the world where e has
not e is true
and if you enter this world we're not
es2 there's no chance that e happens
so in conditional probability you enter
a new universe where everything on the
right of this line has occurred
and then you ask the question on the
left of the line
yeah
that you've just rolled a six
yeah because if you're saying what's it
probably a dice one is one given that
dice one was a six zero it's a six
but if there's two dice you can say
what's probably dice one equals one
given dice two equals six that's totally
legitimate and if you think about
multiple roles of the same dice I would
distinguish those in some way I'd be
like the first rule is one given the
second rule is a six or something like
that
very very good question yes if something
so you're talking about PF having a
probability of zero right yeah
the probability of zero does that
necessarily mean it can't happen yeah
because what's the probability that you
pick a certain number on a scale from
zero to one
interesting you know I would talk about
it as being like a limit probability we
can get into that but like if you tell
me something that's probably easier and
if you're right if you could be wrong
you might say it's probably zero but
you're wrong like the probably the sun
doesn't rise you could say it's probably
zero and then you're wrong and one day
it doesn't rise and you observed The
Impossible
um but if you're right and it's truly
probably zero can't happen
yeah
yes
okay
uh this is also just a gentle
introduction to why probability is so
exciting why we decide to offer this
course of cs109 because as a computer
scientist you're going to be interacting
with data a lot and you're going to use
computers to understand that data and
language is really the or sorry
probability is really the language where
these two things come together
um you might sometimes see people
referring to that simple example we did
before as machine learning machine
learning is just a nice euphemism for
people who know probability and can do
some data with computer science at the
same time
okay I want to take a moment though
and distinguish three concepts we've
talked about unfortunately people across
the world of probability use lots of
different notations for them but we've
got the probability of and of events the
probability of the ore of events and the
conditional probability of one event
given another
events are things that can happen
the probably event what's the chance
that they both happen
different from this what's the probably
one happens given I tell you the other
one has happened subtly different but
very importantly different and the
probability of or saying that either e
or F will happen three different
concepts and I just put up those
notations that so you can check later
and make sure you don't get confused
somebody writes this they mean and they
write this they mean and if they write
and thank you for saying what you mean
uh same they write this they mean or or
if they write or they mean or and those
are two concepts are very different from
the conditional probably Constable which
might be new for you
okay uh I was thinking about baby poop
when I was writing this lecture and so
now we have a baby poop example
I have a baby in the morning when she
wakes up there's a 50 chance that she's
pooped in the night or not
uh and it's not always the case that she
cries when she wakes up and it's not
always the case that she cries if she
has poop but if she has a poop there's a
50 chance that she cries
so I want us to think what's the
probability that the baby has pooped and
cried and we're going to use this as a
chance to try and separate our
difference between uh probability of and
and the probability of or and here I
included the definition conditional
probably and the probability of and and
I want to point out that this question
has the word and in it so what's the
probability that the baby has pooped and
cries
think about it for a second
and then I wanted to take a moment and
Define some events uh I'm going to do e
for excrement
I can't use P why don't I use p
yeah super confusing when there's all
these Capital P's around so this is
going to be the event of pooped
and we need a vent for cries why
shouldn't I use k a c for cry
compliment oh my gosh okay so what are
we gonna use for cry we'll use like tea
for Tears
cries
this question is asking what's the
probability of E
and T
it's also given us some information we
said the probability of e is 50 and then
there's this line the chance that the
baby cries given that she has pooped is
50 what is that telling us
so the probability that the baby has
pooped
or sorry the baby cries
tea
given that the baby has pooped
is 50 percent
so this is hopefully just
straightforward once you recognize
everything that's written as a straight
example of something called The Chain
rule so it says there's a 50 chance that
the baby poops and if the baby poops
there's a 50 chance that the baby cries
what's the probability that the baby
poops and cries
I hear it somebody tell me loud and
proud 25 25 you can just multiply these
you know the relationship between
probability of and and conditional
probability is given by these two
formulas which are uh isomorphic
versions of themselves so this one is
saying the probability of two things
happening the and of them is the
probability of one thing probably times
probably the other thing given that
first thing so she poops and then she
cries given that she poops if you
multiply these two numbers together you
get the and so they're different and in
condition are two different things and
there's a mathematical relationship that
governs their how similar they are so
the probability of this is going to be
equal to the chain rule which will be
those two things multiply together
you're exactly right it's one over four
fantastic
uh and you know the point here is that
people will find and and conditioning
complicated maybe you should pause here
for anyone who is thinking probably the
end and probably a condition where the
same thing we could pause here and see
if there's a good question
life of a parent man lots and lots of
poop yes is the reason why
why ordering of it is that why they're
like two separate things
good the ordering does matter okay so
when we say that ordering I often think
about conditional probabilities the
probability of ordering an and doesn't
matter
ENT is the same as T and E they're both
happening it doesn't matter which one
probably if T given e is actually
different from the probability of e
given t let's think about them
semantically
and these are not the same
the probability of you crying given that
you pooped is not the same as the
probably that you pooped given you cry
there are two different universes one we
know you're crying and we're trying to
figure out whether or not you pooped the
other one we know you pooped and we're
trying to figure out whether or not
you're crying and they're two different
probabilities so in conditional
probabilities order really really does
matter
so going off that in this case if we
only have a probability that
they cried and then we had the
probability that they cried giving cheap
food we wouldn't be able to solve this
right is that like what you're saying
yeah there's lots of versions where I
have not given you enough information to
solve this I happen to give you exactly
the information you needed to solve this
and so if I've given you for example if
I've given you the wrong conditional
probability here there may be no way to
solve that very good question yes
yeah
our cases uh where where these two
things could be equal it's just we don't
know they're equal but yeah there's some
cases and it's more just luck if it
turns out that they're equal
okay
fantastic
the chain rule is very helpful the chain
rules what we just used and it says the
probability of two things happening is
the probably of one thing times probably
the other thing given the first thing
and it turns out you can chain rule as
much as you want if there's like the
probability of
event one end event two and event three
and event n happening
you can take the chain Rule and just
keep going you can say what's it
probably that event one happens
times are probably that event two
happens given event one happened
and then this is some weird notation
like what is going on here
this is saying what's the chance that
event three has happened give an event
one inventory it happened
you enter the world where I know event
one and two have happened and I asked
what's the question that event three has
happened
and this kind of seems like logical it's
like the chance that event one happened
okay now I know event one happened
what's the chance that event two
happened now that I know those two
events have happened what's the chance
event three happen and that's a chance
of all three of them happening that's
what the chain Rule's stating
okay
whoo you guys are ready for a law that
is so useful it gets the name of the law
of total probability are you guys ready
to dive in
let's go back to poop so let's go back
to this world where I give you the
probability of uh the baby pooping I
give you the probability that the baby
cries given that she's pooped
and now I want to ask you the question
what's the chance that when you wake up
the baby's crying
and I'm not giving you enough
information
you can't calculate the probability that
the baby's crying I've only told you a
chance that she's pooped and the chance
that she cries given that she's pooped
and I want you to just take a moment and
try to invent some probability what is
the information that you're missing if
you would want to be able to say the
probability that she's crying
and this is pushing you to kind of
invent the law of total probability but
talk to the person next to you for a
second and let us do it says do this
together
okay does somebody have an idea it's
totally fine if you can't invent this we
will tell you
but maybe somebody invented it yeah in
the back
you cried given that she didn't poop
yeah there's two worlds that can lead to
her crying either poop but it's totally
possible that she's crying when there's
no poop and I don't know what's the
probability that she cries given no poop
and no poop mathematically I write as e
complement excrement compliment and
that's what we're missing that's exactly
what we're missing and if we had that
what that would lead to would be the law
of total probability
the law of total probably says if I want
to know the probability that my baby
cried or some event
and there's some background of events
like pooping or not pooping the law of
toad probably says you can figure out
the probability that she cries by
thinking about these two cases either
she cries and there's poop or she cries
and there is no poop
and because those are mutually exclusive
events by the third accident of
probability if you can figure out the
probably that she cries and there's poop
and you can figure out the probability
she cries and there's no poop
then you can just add up those two
probabilities
so just to make this clear I only care
about the problem that she cries but
there's this background process
of poop or no poop and you know since
pooper no poop spans the entire space
you can think about crying as coming
from either this set of outcomes or the
no poop set of outcomes is that making
sense
it's a hard one but if you get this
that's the law of children probability
you can kind of decompose your
calculation the probability of crying
into these two cases crying with poop
and crying with no poop I can't believe
how many times a managers say poop in a
Stanford class
uh okay does this make sense though
right you're like your e can either come
from E and F and E and not f
these two sets must be mutually
exclusive because it's not possible for
both F and not F to both happen at the
same time so your Mutual exclusive
events so the probability space here can
be added to probably a space here to get
the probability of my event I care about
in blue
this does generalize oh by the way once
you get with this statement each of
these probabilities can then be to
decompose you to the chain rule
E and F can be probably e given F times
probably of F and E and F complement can
be the probability of e given F
component times the probability of f
complement just using the chain rule on
both of those uh pieces
so that is the law of total probability
if you want to know probability of e you
can use this calculation to solve it
and you know there is a proof here for
those of one who want to see the
complete list but I really think that
this example is going to drive it home
the thing we were missing was the
probability of crying given no poo so
let's make that up and let's see if we
can solve this
the probability of her crying given no
poop
let's say that equals one over eight
if I told you that this was one over
eight what's the probability that she
cries
the probability that she cries oh a
whole bunch of Bits good
the probability that she cries
is going to be either equal to
the case where she cries
and there is poop so the chance that she
wait I want probably of crying tears so
tears given poop times the probability
of poop
plus probably of Tears given no poop
times the probability of no poop
what's the probability of poop
yeah one half
what's the probability of Tears giving
poop
we're told it's one half what's the
probability of no poop oh I didn't tell
you that
one question how do you know it's one
half declare every people
I know that one minus this probability
will be the probability of its
complement
and now we say the missing information
is probably that she cries given she
didn't prove and we said you know
there's a one in eight chance of that
this probability gives us doesn't tell
us what this probability is being told
the probability she cries given poop
doesn't give us any information about
whether or not she cries when there's no
poop those are two different worlds and
two different outcomes for probabilities
and if you think about this case and add
in this mutually exclusive case we have
both cases where she's crying either
crying with poop or crying with no poop
there you have it the love total
probability what a poopy explanation
okay now we're going to bump this up a
notch and try and do something a little
bit more interesting
so see if you can use a lot of total
probability and practice this world of
taking a word problem and figuring out
what are the probability events and what
are the formulas I can use
bacteria can that can cause a disease
let's say 10 of those bacteria have a
mutation which make them resistant to
antibiotics
you take half a course never take half a
course if they say take the full course
take the full course because if you take
out of course what happens
Evolution your bacteria
or evolves and the process is basically
that the bacteria that has mutations are
much more likely to survive
and bacteria that don't have mutation
they're much less likely to survive so
the survivors end up being filled with
mutated bacteria
but my question for you is what's the
probability that a bacteria survives
and this is a hard question it's
invoking this very complicated thing the
law of total probability and it's
invoking your ability to read a word
problem and pull out all of these
probabilities
step one if you're finding this hard
Define events and once you have events
try and figure out everything the
problem is telling you and see if you
can solve it
so take a moment and we will think about
this together in just a moment too
feel free to talk if you want
okay
your process is first to Define events
I've got an event bacteria has a
mutation I call that M for mutation
bacteria survives I call that s
for survives
now my next thing the problem tells me a
lot of information and it defines a
challenge it says what's the probability
that bacteria survives it wants to know
probability of s
but it's given me a bunch of information
the first thing it says 10 of mutations
uh okay ten percent of bacteria have a
mutation
that's not telling me a conditional
probability that's telling me an
unconditional probability it's saying
that the probability of mutation equals
10 percent
it then gives me more information it
says the probability of bacteria
survives given it has mutation it's 20
that given is a dead giveaway that's
talking about conditional probability
it's telling me the probability
of survival giving mutation equals 2 out
of ten
and the last sentence is probably
bacteria survives given it doesn't have
the mutation as one percent it's telling
me the probability of survival given no
mutation equals one over a hundred
so I know probably of M probably s given
M and probably s given M complement
those are directly told but guess what
there's three hidden probabilities that
you're told which are not explicitly
written
if I know probability of M I also know
probably them complement
what's the probability that something
doesn't have the mutation
yeah it's clever students good times but
I tell you that there's three pieces of
information
I'm also telling you the probability of
s complement given m
is eight out of ten
you need to know a really important
thing about conditional probabilities
if you enter the world where M happens
all laws of probability still hold
and condition on this world M the
probability of s given m is going to
plus the probability of s complement
given m is going to equal one it's like
m is the world we've entered where
there's mutation and in that world all
laws of probability hold so it's still
the case that probably S Plus probably s
complement equals one in the world where
m is uh true so this we don't need but I
just want you guys to know that you also
have this information
okay
so a lot of information was given to you
in the problem but what we want is the
probability of s so notice my three
steps wanted to find events two I pull
out all the information for my problem
and three then I try and solve for the
thing I care about probability of s how
can I get there
corner
yeah we could use the log total
probability
there's two different background
processes either it has a mutation or it
doesn't so the probability of s can be
the probability of it of s n mutation
plus the probability of s and not
mutation
particularly you know you'd have to take
this equation and replace every t with
an s
and you'd have to replace every e with
an m
and you get the probability of s is
equal to the probability that it
survives given has a mutation times it
probably has a mutation do we know this
yes
do you know this
you can all say it loud
okay do we know M complement
yes do we know s given M compliments
do we have all of your information we
need to plug a chug
um uh anyways the log total probability
helps us solve this problem but the
really important thing is this process
of pulling out events uh defining what
you get from the problem and then you
can just plug and chug
okay law of total probability we'll get
into this later when we use it more but
there is a big brother version of the
raw of top probability where you can
have background events which aren't
necessarily complements but if
background events span the whole space
and they're mutually exclusive there's a
more grown-up version of Love 12
probability which we'll talk about when
we need it I just wanted to mention it
for the first time now for now though I
really want you to start to feel
comfortable with this version of the law
of total probability
okay
it's not the real question though is it
we don't often care about the
probability that a bacteria survives
what we really care about was what's the
probability that of surviving bacteria
has the mutation
we really care about the probability of
mutation given survival you're like
isn't that given right here we're told
about the probably survival given
mutation
but someone asked a good question before
does the order and conditioning matter
and I said absolutely does matter if I
tell you the probability of survive
mutation you don't know the other
conditional probability
but there's a way to find out and this
is an idea that changed everything in
fact one of the the books I brought in
and the the second day of class was the
the idea that would not die
it's an idea that has changed
mathematics and then it changed computer
science for mathematics and it's
something that's shown up like 10 times
independently in my research it is a
beautiful beautiful idea that can allows
you to go from conditional probably in
one direction to conditional probability
another Direction one of the great
things you'll walk out of cs109 knowing
and we're going to see it for the first
time today
okay
so so far
we've talked about how you can use the
chain Rule and definitely probability to
go between E and F and the probability
of e given f
we've talked about the law of total
probability which can allow you to use
conditional probabilities and get back
to an unconditioned probability
and it's now time to learn how you can
go from a probability of a condition in
One Direction and figure out the
probability condition the other
direction
it's time for some base theorem
okay we're going to tell you about beta
sermon first I need to introduce you to
Tom and Bays um he was English
Presbyterian Ministry invented Bayes
theorem he didn't name after yourself
somebody else named it after him after
he passed away and I'm going to say look
remarkably similar to Sean Aston who
played many important characters in many
important movies but that's not
important right now
Bayes was thinking about this math
problem which might have popped into
your mind
I care about calculating the probability
of the state of the world given some
observation
and I don't know how to do that it turns
out in some situations the opposite's
easy I can know the probability of some
observation given a true state of the
world
and how can I go from one to the other
and he was pondering this mathematical
question when he came up with what was
one of the most profound important
contributions to mathematics that's
entered computer science but also turns
out to be you know kind of reasonable
given what you've learned so far
so to be clear he knows the probability
of condition in One Direction he wants
to know that probably in the other
direction in the real world it often
follows that there's something of
unobserved that you care about inferring
and there's some observation that you
see and it's it's much easier to know
the probability of the observation given
the thing you infer rather than the
probability of the thing you care about
given your observation don't worry too
much about that but we'll see lots of
real world examples I'll keep referring
to that and it'll make more sense as we
go
but he was trying to figure out how you
can go from one condition to the other
direction and he started with this
definition of conditional probability I
imagine he stared at it and he had he
had a little lamp and the light was
fading and just before the light faded
he's like
oh my gosh
I can just plug the chain rule in to the
probability of and
because the chain rule says the
probability of E and F is probably e
given F times the probability of F and
you're like wait isn't the chain rule in
definition conditional probability like
aren't they just opposites of each other
if you plug this in should everything
just cancel out
well there's two versions of the chain
rule you can say e and f is equal to e
given F times probably F or you can say
probably if E and F is probably F given
e times the probability of e both are
true
one of these totally cancels out and the
other leaves you with a deep theorem in
mathematics
so you just plug two rules into each
other and he was left with this identity
which gave us a way to calculate the
probability of one conditional given the
other
and I imagine the next day he was
looking as like that's beautiful I think
he just probably spent a whole day just
weeping on his parchment just like this
is so gorgeous I can't believe we can
finally calculate the probability of
condition given the other direction and
then he's like but wait we can go
further
he's like this is all good and fun but
maybe this denominator term is sometimes
hard to find and he's just like
I'm just going to plug in the law of
total probability so basically this
Presbyterian Minister plugs three math
formulas into each other like all known
math formulas it becomes like the most
famous mathematician of all time you're
like I could have totally done that if I
was born in like I don't know 1705 but
anyways Bays got there at first uh he
figured out that you can plug all these
identities into each other and you can
get a way for calculating the
probability of one conditional given the
other this looks very intimidating
especially because I wrote one too many
probably uh of ease
just to make you guys feel a little bit
more intimidated uh it still feels like
a lot of
um terms but it turns out you know these
oh man how did I do that
again a little too excited
um technically though that's right
because you'd factor out the probably
bathroom though just cancel but um but
this is the the actual formula of Base
theorem that you'll see on something
like Wikipedia this two terms you know
they're the same as these two terms so
even though there's a bunch of turns
here those two are the same as here
um
Jesus
I got my chain rule wrong typing too
fast okay
uh
and and those two terms are different
but there's really only four unique
terms you'd need to figure out the
probability of conditional probably the
other ways here is it stated correctly
I mean Bayes theorem is really saying
that you can calculate one conditional
probably the other way around uh and
there's two versions of Bayes theorem if
you go to Wikipedia it will quote you
this one that's basically just
conditional definition with the chain
rule stuck into it uh but often in cs19
you'll want the expanded form where you
just take that bottom thing and apply
the law of total probability
okay
we're going to take this out for a spin
here's a real world example that follows
the pattern where Bayes theorem becomes
so useful
you care about whether or not something
is spam
so you want to know whether or not
something spam email and You observe
something about the email in this case
I'm going to say that the email has the
word dear in it
what we would like to know is what's the
probability that spam email an email is
Spam given it has the word dear in it
but the other direction is much easier
to know if you want to know the
probability that an email has a word
dear knit given it spam you can go
through your database of spam emails and
just count what fraction have the word
dear in them
but in the real world when you're trying
to detect spam you don't care about the
chance that spam email has the word deer
in it you care about whether or not
you're looking at spam email
and you're given the information that
the email has the word dear in it so you
want the opposite of what's easy to
measure and Bayes theorem says that we
can just apply uh this formula to go
from one formulation to another
here's what a Bayes theorem question
could look like and I put the formula up
in the top right corner
sixty percent of all email is spam you
need to know the background probability
um of f in this case
you need that twenty percent of all Spam
has the word dear so that's the
probability
of the of One Direction and you'd like
to know the probability of the condition
the other direction and then you need to
know what's the probability uh
that F complement
you need this probability stated you
need to have these three probabilities
stated
why are those three probabilists data
those are the three that are included
here why is it not necessary to know the
probability of f complement
yeah yeah okay that super important hint
from the beginning of the warm-up says
classes come a whole bunch of times the
probability of f complement is equal to
1 minus the probability of f so if I
tell you 60 of all email is Spam forty
percent is not spam
if you get an email with the word dear
in it can you now update a probability
that the word is Spam sometimes you'll
see this called belief you know what's
your new belief that an email spam given
that it has the word dear in it
well let's define our events so I'm
going to say e is the event that the
email has deer in it and F is the event
that it has that is Spam and this will
make it perfectly match the Bayes
theorem formula
identify All the known probabilities in
this case you know we have probability
of f the probability of
D or sorry e given F and we have the
probability of e given F complement
and then once you have those you're just
going to plug those values into Bayes
theorem and you are done
so
interestingly these terms in base
theorem they have names
this probability F we call it the prior
it's your belief in spam before you saw
that it had the word dear in it so it's
your belief prior to observing deer and
this is your belief After You observe
dear
the chance that is Spam and the chance
of spam given that it has the word deer
in it
and it's kind of like you're taking this
old probability and updating it given
the evidence of the word dear
you need to know the likelihood of the
evidence what's the probability of deer
given that it's spam and then you have
to do this normalization at the bottom
we're using the law of total probability
okay
and if you just plug this in you would
get the probability of something being
spam given it has the word during it
one of the most canonical examples of
Bayes theorem is talking about medical
tests and this has shown up a lot in our
lives now that we've had to live with
covid for like almost three years
let's not talk about covet for a second
but let's talk about SARS and let's talk
about it a medical test for to testing
whether or not somebody has SARS
these medical tests
are operating you know at what we call a
98 effective rate so if somebody has
SARS there's a 98 chance that it tells
you they have SARS and there's a two
percent chance it tells you they don't
have SARS so there's this truth about
the person the person either has SARS or
not but the test is not perfect
the observation you get could say this
person has SARS even though they don't
or it could say they don't have SARS
even they do this is saying that if they
have SARS 98 of time it says they do
it has a false positive rate of one
percent which means that if they don't
have SARS one percent of the time it
says they do
so probability of saying it has SARS
given that they don't is one percent
a very small percentage of the US
population we're going to say has SARS
when this test is run
and I'm going to Define these events to
get us started is the event that you
test positive for SARS and F is the
event that you actually have stars
if we did this all together
the probability that we really care
about in this one is what's the
probability that someone actually has
SARS given that they got a positive test
so imagine you're at the doctor and said
you just had a positive test for SARS
you're like oh no
what does that mean well it's not
conclusive that you actually do have
SARS instead we want to know what's the
probability that you do have SARS
so the problem that you actually have
stars given that you tested positive
base thermally said that this is the
probability of e given f
times the probability of f
and then we would use the law of total
probability to say that this is the
probability of e given f
times the probability of f
plus the probability of e given not f
times the probability of not f
okay what's the probability of f what's
the probability that somebody has SARS
given no other information
0.05 wait 0.005
because it's point five percent of the
US population if it was five percent of
the US population
0.05.005 is uh half a percentage of the
usual population
so we know this number two this is also
0.05 and this number of here is going to
be 0.995
so 99.5 percent of the population
doesn't have SARS unconditioned on any
other information
but how about this one do I know the
probability of e given F what's the
probability of the test saying they have
SARS given they actually do have SARS
98 is 98 effective at saying you have
SARS given that you do have SARS so 0.98
that's this number over here
and the last number I need is the
probability that you have SARS given
that or sorry the probability that the
test says you have SARS given that you
don't have SARS
if you don't have SARS
it has a false positive rate of one
percent if you don't have SARS there's a
one percent chance that it says you do
if you take all these numbers you can
now just plug and chunk and if you
plugged and chugged you would get that
there's a 33 chance that you have SARS
isn't that crazy
you walked into the doctors they tested
you for SARS it says yes you have SARS
and still your chance of having SARS is
only one in three
craziness Bayes theorem gives you the
ability to know exactly what is your
updated belief in this case that ability
to know the exact probability is very
useful because there's this one really
confounding factor and the one really
confounding factor is that very very
very few people in the background
population have SARS so even this tiny
false positive rate can lead to a
situation where you're still less likely
to have it if you test positive I wanted
to take a moment to go over intuition
here's all people in the United States
here is that half a percent of people
who have SARS
some of the people most of the people
who have SARS are going to test positive
but a whole bunch of people who don't
have SARS are going to test positive too
there's two ways that you can test
positive you have SARS and you test
positive
or you don't have SARS and you get what
we call a false positive
but it turns out there's so many people
who don't have SARS that if you enter
the world of all the people who test
positive
there's still more people in that world
who didn't have SARS and had a false
positive than people who did have SARS
and got a test
I actually thought it would be easier to
make this point by drawing you a picture
of everybody in the United States I'm
gonna make a person here or imagine a
thousand the US is represented by a
thousand people
if only point five percent of people
have SARS
you've only got these five people with
SARS and all these people don't have
SARS imagine every single one of these
five test positive
out of these 995 people who don't have
SARS most people test negative
but one percent of them test positive
when we condition on the fact of testing
positive we enter the world where we're
looking at only the people who tested
positive and in this world there's more
people who didn't have SARS and tested
positive than there were people who did
have SARS and tested positive and the
ratio is exactly one-third
isn't that wild
Bayes is a mathematical identity I
really do think of it as two equations
put together but there are two equations
put together that can lead you to very
surprising results and when you get
surprising results that's often where
you get power for results and possibly
that's why this equation shows up in so
many algorithms for computer science
I do actually talk about why it's still
good to get tested you can calculate the
probability of having SARS given that
you got a negative test result and your
chance that you get have SARS given
negative test result is actually very
very very very very very very small
anyways not that important right now
I put in one last example if for people
who want to have a little bit more
examples with uh Bayes theorem
and that's where we're going to leave it
for today in fact I'm just going to
State this and I'm we're going to answer
it at the end so this is something you
should be able to do by the end of the
day if you feel like you can't do it
take some time with it between now and
next class because this is really really
our learning goal
this is a cool example imagine you want
to know the probability that somebody
knows a concept and All You observe is
whether or not they get a multiple
choice question correct
there's a lot of probabilities that
people have in education Theory
they say if somebody doesn't know the
answer to multiple choice question
there's a one-fourth chance that they
can get it right
now if somebody knows a question they
don't always get it right uh or sorry
not everyone knows the concept going in
so let's say three quarters of your
population knows the concept going in
there's a chance to guess it right just
because it's multiple choice and there's
a chance that they get it wrong even if
they know it sometimes the people who
know a concept will slip and just make a
mistake
could you put all this information to
infer the thing we really care about
what's the chance that they really
understand a concept given that we
observed a correct answer
this is the sort of thing you should be
able
to beautiful tool you have with Bayes
theorem see if you can do this if you
can't do it practice they come back on
Wednesday and we will take this to the
next level also on Wednesday
sorry I wanted to promise you something
on Wednesday we're going to gamble so
learn this stuff so you can come see us
online make some money
foreign